-Welcome to the show.
I'm so happy to to meet you.
I'm a big fan.
I listen to your stuff.
You're fantastic.
-Thank you.
I'm a huge fan of you, Jimmy.
-Oh. Thank you. I mean --
I mean, "Call Her Daddy."
This is the thing.
Everyone is talking about this.
Your interview skills
are fantastic.
You get people to do stuff and
get into stories that I'm like,
"How did she get
people to do that?"
Time 100 Next just named you
on their list
in the top 100 right there.
So congratulations on that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
How does it all, uh...
How's it --
How's it all feeling?
-It feels surreal.
Like, I still feel like the girl
from Pennsylvania,
like, that's awkward
with my braces in the basement,
just, like, trying to make it.
-Yeah.
-It's very surreal,
but I'm just so happy
that it's happening.
And it's happening.
-Your --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Your bigger news is that
you got engaged this year.
-I did.
-Congratulations on this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
But wait till you hear this.
The proposal
was pretty elaborate,
and I kind of --
I can't even believe
that this is a real thing.
But dreams come true. This is --
This is what I wish I did.
But please walk us
through what he did.
-Okay. Well, just to, like,
set the ground here,
I was the girl
that never thought
she was going to get married.
Like, I had no interest.
I never had the Pinterest board.
I don't even I still don't even
know what my dress will be.
Like, there is no vision, Jimmy.
Okay?
So we're starting with nothing.
-No Pinterest board.
-Yes, there is nothing. Okay?
So, I remember --
And I think it was because
I was nervous that it threatened
my independence as a woman.
And so that changed, obviously,
when I met Matt.
And from the very beginning
of our relationship,
I'm like, "We are
never getting married.
We are life partners, okay?"
And he's like, "Okay.
Oh, my God, you're wacky."
And then I will never forget.
I sat him down at a dinner
at Giorgio Baldi in L.A.
and I was like, "Matt,
I have to tell you something."
And he's like, "What?"
And I'm like, "You can do it."
He's like, "I can do what?"
And I'm like, "You can propose.
We can get married."
And he's like -- he's elated.
Like, he's so happy.
And it was
such a cute moment.
And then a couple months later,
he did it in the most
romantic possible way.
I mean, Matt produces Y.A. films
for a living, so this --
I felt like I was in a movie.
Okay?
I got home,
I walk in, and Adele
is playing all
throughout our house.
Every square inch of my home
has candles all over it,
and there is a video of him
that basically says,
follow the scavenger hunt,
and you will come find me.
And every room in our home.
He had picture frames of themes,
so the kitchen was filled with
all picture frames
of our firsts -- the first trip
that he said, "I love you,"
the first time
we went to Hawaii,
he met my parents.
Like, it was so touching.
And then at the end, once I went
through the scavenger hunt,
I saw him with
our two dogs in tuxedos
underneath this, like, gazebo,
and he got down on one knee,
and it was perfect!
Oh, my God!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now, are people upset with Matt?
Are people mad at Matt and go,
"Hey, dude,
calm it down a little bit"?
-It was pretty --
It was pretty crazy.
I remember reading on Twitter,
and men were like,
"Matt, Matt,
can we tone it down?"
Like, because girlfriends
are like,
"Oh, I'm showing
my boyfriend this."
Alex being like,
"I expect nothing less."
And I was like, "Let's go!"
-Yeah.
Congratulations.
That's the way to do it.
That's awesome. I want to talk
about your new tour,
by the way, as well,
because you're going on
this tour
called The Unwell Tour,
and you're going to put some
bachelorette-party vibes
into this tour.
But explain to me what this tour
is so people know,
fans of you will know.
-So, what I will say
is, obviously,
because it's bachelorette-themed
and this is network television,
Jimmy, I can't -- I can't go
into too much detail,
but what I will say is,
I have never been
live in person with my fans.
I call them the Daddy Gang.
Love you. Shout-out Daddy Gang!
[ Cheers and applause ]
And I always try to do things
and, like, flip it on its head.
Like, how can I reinvent
something?
How can I think of something
different to give my audience?
And when you think
of a podcast tour,
you think,
"I'm gonna do this.
We're gonna sit for an hour
and a half, we're gonna chat,
we're going to talk."
Absolutely not.
To give you a little taste,
my lighting team came up to me,
and they said,
"Alex, we have worked
on Broadway shows before, babe.
Okay? This show
has more lighting cues
than some Broadway shows,"
and I'm like, "Let's go!"
So it's gonna be amazing.
I'm really excited.
I'm really excited
for my fans to see it.
And I'm not going to lie,
I'm nervous
because I've never
done something live.
But it feels right.
It feels right.
-Oh, that's great.
I know you're coming --
coming to the Theater
at the Garden, too,
here in New York.
-Yeah. You're gonna come, right?
-I will totally be there.
Are you kidding me?
What, are you kidding me?
-Absolutely.
-What is it? Five years now
you're celebrating?
-Five years.
-Congratulations, pal.
Really. Well done.
I -- I love it.
It's so good.
Do you hear from people?
Do people come up to you and go,
"Hey, you changed my life," or,
"Thank you for doing that thing.
I didn't think of it that way"?
What is the best compliment?
-I've got it for you.
Okay. One time,
I'm standing in CVS,
and this girl comes up to me,
and she's like,
"Alex,
I have to tell you a story,"
and I'm like, "Okay.
Tell me the story."
She's like, "I had a man
come up to me,
and he was like,
'I hate Alex Cooper.'"
And she's like,
"What do you mean?
Why do you hate Alex Cooper?"
And he's like,
"She is making women
way too confident."
And I'm like, "Oh, my God.
I can retire now."
Like, it's such a cool moment
to realize that women
actually come to my show
and can feel better
about themselves.
I've had women stop me
in the street and be like,
"I got out of
an abusive relationship
because of the show."
"I went in and advocated
for myself
and got that raise I wanted."
Like, it's a community
that has been built
with a bunch of women
that are like-minded,
and I'm so proud of it,
and it's just going
to keep going.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I think it's awesome
that you're doing that.
-Thank you.
Thank you.
-People --
Today is Halloween,
and people are dressing up
as you, by the way.
I saw a lot online.
There being you for Halloween.
Does that feel odd?
-It's a little odd.
But what I will say is, like,
I'm looking out for the girlies.
Like, if you're gonna
dress up like me,
obviously, if I was actually
wearing what I wanted to be
in right now,
every single Daddy Gang
knows I'd be in sweatpants
and a hoodie and my messy bun,
and that is what
they're wearing.
You just got to throw
on a sweatsuit
and a messy bun, and you're
like, "I'm Alex Cooper."
-There you go.
So that's a good costume.
-There we go.
-But I also know your your dog
Henry dresses up every year.
-He does.
-And I've heard --
Look at this cute dog.
People recognize this dog.
-This is Cindy Lou Who
right here. Okay?
-I mean, stop it.
He's so cute.
And people, actually,
they come up to him
on the street and like,
and they're like,
"Oh, you're Henry."
-They say, "Oh, my God, Alex,
I didn't notice you at first
because I --
but I saw Henry, and then
I was like, 'Oh, it's you.'"
Yeah. They look for Henry.
I'm like, "Okay."
-Yeah, well, I thought --
I was like,
"What is Henry going to be
this year for Halloween?"
and you were gonna tell me
and show a picture,
but then you're going to --
again, you're upping the game
and doing something
that's something different.
You actually brought
Henry here in person.
-Mm-hmm.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I did.
-Can we bring him out?
-Can I go get him?
-Let's go get Henry.
-Henry!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hi, buba.
-Henry.
-Come here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come here.
-Oh, my gosh.
Henry.
-Hi, buba!
-Henry.
-Hi!
Oh. Hi, Henry. Are you --
Oh. Thank you.
I don't have a treat yet,
but you're a nice burrito.
Henry.
-Yeah, he's a little burrito.
You guys, I may have put
the costume on wrong,
but we're going to pretend
that didn't happen. Sit.
It's okay, Jimmy, he'll give you
his paw if you ask for his paw,
but he can only
give his left one,
so, like, you know,
be easy on him.
-Oh, should we do it
over this way then?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah. Sit.
-Right. Here we go. Sit.
-Sit. Paw.
Good boy!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my God!
Henry, wait.
You want me to do it?
Let me do it.
-Yeah, yeah, give another one.
You got it, you got it.
-I want a Henry --
-Henry, sit. Paw.
Ask for paw first.
-Paw.
-Good, baby.
-Oh, what a good boy!
Happy Halloween.
Happy Halloween!
Alex Cooper!
New episodes of "Call Her Daddy"
stream every Wednesday
on Spotify.
We'll be right back with a
performance from Depeche Mode.
Stick around.
You want another one?